楽しみですね 読経をはじめて何年なんだかわからないくらいです
ア
タコーバガワーヤスマーングリマーレーナパッチャーサマネーナエーナサーヴァーティテーナチャーリカンパッカーミアヌプッベーナチャーリカンチャロマノーエーヌサーヴァーティタダワサリー
それからお釈迦様がこのアングリマーラというお坊さんと一緒に
そのお坊さんはパッチャーサマネーナ
自分が後ろから来る人としてという意味なんですね
エーナサーヴァーティテーナチャーリカンパッカミ
サーヴァーティの方へまた旅に出ましたということですね
チャーリカンパッカミっていうのはパッカミ
アヌプッベーナチャーリカンチャロマノー
それで順番で徐々にチャーリ
あのサーヴァーティ歩きながらエーナサーヴァーティテーナタダワサリー
サーヴァーティという街に入りました
タトラスダンバガワーサーヴァーティヤンビヘレティジェートワニヤナートピンディガッサーラーミ
その時お釈迦様がこのジェートワナというお寺で住むことになりました
テーナコーパナサマエーナランニョパセーナディッサコーサラッサアンテプラドワレーマハージャナカヨサッニパティットワウッチャーサッドマハサッドアホシー
テーナコーパナサマエーナというのはその時
ランニョパセーナディッサコーサラッサ
このパセーナディッコーサラという王のアンテプラドワレー
アンテプラというのは中の街という意味なんですけど
いわゆる王様の宮殿のあるところなんですね
そこら辺の玄関のところで
マハージャナカヨサッニパティットワ
たくさん人々が集めてウッチャーサッドマハサッドアホシー
ものすごく大騒ぎしているんですね
チョーローテーデーヴァヴィジテーアングリマーローナーマルッドーローヒタパーニハタパハテーニビッドアデヤーパンノーパーナーブーテース
デーヴァっていうのは王様を呼ぶ時
一応呼ぶ言葉で デーヴァというのは神という言葉なんですけどね
で チョーロー 泥棒がいるんだと
ヴィジテーあなたの国で
国は別な言葉使いますけど
ヴィジタという言葉を使う場合は
その王様の統治している国っていう意味なんですね
誰かが統治している国の場合はヴィジタと呼ぶんですね
ですから それは王様に対して使う言葉で
私たちには使えない 私のヴィジタとは言えません
私は何も支配 統治しているわけじゃないんだから
ですから この統治している人が言うものの場合は
そこに使う言葉なんです
アングリマーローナーマ
アングリマーラという名前でルッドーローヒタパーニ
ものすごく残酷で ローヒタパーニ血まみれまで
ハタパハテー もう何だかんでも殺していく人でニビッドアデヤーパンノー
何の優しさもない パーナブーテース
生命に対しては何の優しさもない
ものすごい泥棒がいるんだそうだ
テーナガーマーピアガマーカタ
村をもう村でなくなっちゃったと
ニガマーピアニガマーカタ
もっと大きな村というか
村の群れですね 村たくさん集めたらニガマになりますからね
全部もう人がいなくなってしまったと
ジャナパダ地方になってくると
地方にしても地方も人々がいなくなったと
ソーマヌッセワディットワワディットワ
彼が人間を殺して殺してアングリーナンマーランダーレーティ
指の指輪 首輪をかけているんだと
タンデーウォパティセーデートゥティ
タン彼をデーを神様が抑えなさいと
なんとかしなさいということ
アタコーラージャーパセーナディッコーサローパンチャマッテーヒアッササテーヒサーヴァーティヤーニッカミディワディワッサ
エーナアーラモーテーナパーヤーシー
それで王様が コーサラ王様がパンチャマッテーヒアッササテーヒ
アッサは馬ですね  500ぐらいの
馬の軍隊と一緒にサーヴァーティヤーニッカミ
西条から出て西条を出たんですね
出かけたんです ディワディワッサ
昼ですね 朝方か昼ですね
エーナアーラモーテーナパーヤーシー
このアーラモというのはお寺のことで
このアーラモがあるところに
そこら辺に行きましたと
ヤーヴァティコーヤーナッサブーミ
車で行けるところで行って
ヤーネーナガントワ 車で行けるところは車で行って
ヤーナパッチャローヒットは車から降りてパッティコを歩いてイエナバガワーお釈迦さんがいるところにウパサンカミ
まあ行きました ウパサンカミとは言ってからバガワンタンアビワデットはエカマンタンニシでお釈迦様へ用事です
傍らに座ってエカマンタンニシンノーコーラージャナンパセーナリンコーサランバガワーエタダボーチャ
そこで傍らに座ったコーサラ王にお釈迦様はこのようにことを言いますね
キンヌテーマハラージャラージャマガドーセーニオビンビサーロークピトー
キンヌテーマハラージャ
お釈迦様は神とは呼ばないんですね
普通にマハラージャというのは大王という言葉で
そういう言葉で呼ぶんですね
王様なんですかと キンヌ
ラージャマガドーセーニオビンビサーロー
マガダ国のセーニヤビンビサーラという王がテークピトー
あんたと怒ってるんですか？なんですかね
コーサラマガダ国の王でもあなたに対して何か怒ってでもいるんでしょうかと
それはすごい大きな国ですからね
ヴェーサーリカワーリッチェリー
次に大きな国といえばヴェーサーリー国ですね
ヴェーサーリー国のリッチェリーたちが
そちらは王様ではなくても
たくさん人々が統治しているんですね
リッチェリーの族の ですから
このリッチェリーの人々があなたに対して
あなたと怒ったんですかと
アンニェーワパティラージャノ
あるいは他のどこかの国で何か敵の王でも起こっているんでしょうかと
ナコーメーバンテーラージャマガドーセーニオビンビサーロークピトー
違いますと ビンビサーラは怒っているわけじゃない
ナピヴェーサーリカリッチェリー
ウェーサーリー国のリッチェリーたちも怒っているわけじゃない
ナピアンニェーパティラージャノ
他の敵の王でも怒っているわけじゃない
チョーローメーバンテービジテーアングリマーローナーマルッドーローヒタパーニーハタパハテーニミットーアデヤパンノパーナブーテー
アングリマーラという殺人者が入って
大変人を殺してるんだという話ですね
そこでナハンバンテーパティセーディッサーミ
あの人を抑えることは私にはできませんというパーリ語なんですけど
翻訳は尊重 私はその者を
これ読めない 拘禁？拘禁しようとしているのですと
パーリ語だったらナハンという風に
ナハンでしょうに タハンはあまり文法的じゃないんですけど
タンガハンだったらタマハンになりますけどね
ですからタマハンバンテーパティセーディッサーミだったら
私は彼を拘禁しますということになります
文法的にはタンガハンですけどね
どの場合はタマハンになりますけどね
タハン にはなりますかね
ナーハンというのはなんアハン
なるほど とにかく私は私は彼をまあまあ捕まろうとしているんだいということで
そう ナーハンっていうのはすごいややこしい言葉ですね
えっと そう なん ね ねだったら複数になりますから
ねアハンだったらネーハンになっちゃうし
ナンアハンだったらナマハンになっちゃうし
ナマハンっていうことを使わないんだからね
ナーハン 他のところへ出てこないサンディですけど
サンディっていうのは言葉をジョイントにするんだからね
サチ
ェパナトゥアンマハラジャアンゴリマランパッセイヤシーケサマッスンオーハレットゥアカッサーヤーニワッターニアッチャーデットアアガーラスマアナガーリャンパッ
バジタンヴィラタンパーナアティパタヴィラタンアディンナーダーナヴィラタンムサーワーダエーカバッティカンブラフマチャーリンシーラワンタンカリアナダンマンキントイナンカレイヤースティ
サチェ もし トワンアナタワ
王様アナタワ アングリマランパッセイヤシーアングリマーラを見るとするならば
どのようなアングリマーラかと
ケサマッスンオーハレットゥア
まあ髪と髭を剃って カッサーヤーニワッターニアッチャーデットア
この褐色色と言うんですか
その色の服を着て アガーラスマアナガーリャン
家から家ないところで
パッバジタン 出家していると
ヴィラタン もうやめている
パーナアティパタ 殺生からやめている
殺生をやめやめている
ヴィラタンアディンナーダーナ
まあ盗むこともやめている
ヴィラタンムサーワーダ
嘘を言うことからもやめている
エーカバッタン まあ午前中しか食べないことにしている
ブラフマチャーリン まあ妻帯しないという意味なんですけど
まあいわゆるまあそういう欲的な行為も全部やめている
シーラワンタンととても道徳的で戒を守っている
カリャナダンマン 良いことをしている
いわゆる善の方へ良い方向へ行動生きている
道徳もある 戒律を守っている
一食しか食べない そういうふうな性格のアングリマーラ見たならばどうしますかねと
キントイナンカレイヤースティ
あんた彼に何するんですかと
で まあこれは出来事はまあかなり楽に短く書いていると思いますけどね
全部一日で起きた出来事のように注釈書なんかに書いているかもしれませんですけど
一応アングリマーラが暴動を起こしてたくさんの人を殺していると
みんな逃げちゃったところで
まあ王様の国で混乱起きちゃうし
それで王が出て行って
その人を捕まえなくちゃいけないし
そちらで王様が軍隊集めて出てくるという話で
王様の大地のアドバイザーというかね
第一の大臣ですね その人がの奥さん
息子ですからね 王様は一応知ってるんですよ
これはもう自分がすごく尊敬している
自分にいつでもアドバイスしてくれる先輩のバラモン人の息子っていうこと
だから王様はそこら辺でちょっと父親のことを考えて
うーん ちょっと遠慮しているところもあったし
父親はもう諦めて もう法律ですからね
まあもうしょうがないということで
たとえ自分の息子であろうとも
まあしょうがないと 母親は決して嫌いませんしね
母親は父親に頼んだところでもうできませんと言われたら
もうだったら私が行って連れて行くぞと来るんで
それはあんまり頭のいい行為じゃないんだから
ただ人が人を連れてきたんだからといって
犯罪者は犯罪者だからね
だからそれはただの無知な行為で
父親にしたって もう国の犯罪者だから
それはどうすることもできません
たとえ王様個人的には
じゃあもうあなた先生だから
私のね 先生の息子を殺すわけにいきませんという個人的なこと言ったって
王は王だから 国の決まり守らなくちゃいけないし
国民が訴えちゃうとどうにもならないことになるんですね
まあそういう状況で王様はやっぱりもう遠慮しているんだよ
とにかく遠慮しているんですよ
もう行ってなんかどうなることかということで
また その人の人殺しの方法もすごく鋭がしくて
なかなかもう捕めませんし
後ろから攻撃する 攻撃するやり方でやってるんだからね
たとえ軍隊の人でも後ろから攻撃しちゃうと
もうどうにもならんだから
後ろ何人か殺しちゃうと
前にいる人々は怖くなっちゃうし
後ろ振り向き前にやられちゃいますからね
ですから もうたくさんもう軍隊が行ったっても
やっぱりもうもう半分殺し合うと
もうみんな不安の残りは逃げちゃうし
攻撃しようと振り向いてくると
この人は逃げてるんだから
また森の中 とにかくかなりのゲリラ戦争やり方はもう一人でやっていたんです
そこで王様にあんた何するんでしょうかと聞いたら
王様はアビワデーヤマワ・バンテ・パッチュッテッヤーマ・ワ・アッセネーナ・ワ・ニマンテッヤーマ・アビニマンテッヤーマ・ワナン・チーバラピンダ・パータセーナ
・スナ・ギラナ・パッチェ・ベーサッジャ・パリッカーラーヘー・アビワデーヤマ
だったら私は彼を礼をしますと
パッチュッテッヤーマ
で 彼が来ると 私はすぐ座っているところからもう立ちますよと
ここですけど ちゃんと立ちます
アッセネーナ・ワ・ニマンテッヤーマ
すぐ椅子を座らせてあげますと
アビニマンテッヤーマ
接待もしますと お布施もしますと
アビニマンテッヤーマというのは紹介して色々接待することなんですね
何で接待するか チーバラ
衣 ピンダパータ 食べるもの
セーナースナ 住むところ
ギラナ・パッチェ 薬などなどですね
ベーサッジャ・パリッカーラっていうのは他の必要なもの
必需品などなど 何でも私は彼を紹介してお布施しますよと
ダンミカン・ワ・アッサ・ラッカーワラナ・グッティン・サンウィダヘッヤーマ
ダンミカンというのは法によって
その場合は法律ですよ
法によってアッサ 彼にダンミカン・アッサ
彼に法によってラッカーワラナ・グッティン
彼を守ってあげますと
ラッカっていうのは守ること
アーワラナというのはもう囲まってという意味ですね
で グッティンっていうのはまた守りということですね
サンウィダヘッヤーマ
用意しておきますと 法律では出家はもう守るという法律でしたからね
と言って クトーパナッサ・バンテ・ドゥッシーラッサ・パーパ・ダンマッサ・エーワ・ルーポー・シーラ・サンニャマ・バヴィッサ・ティーティ
王様というか もう誰も信じませんだから
クトー そんなあるわけでしょうかと
パナ・アッサ そのようにドゥッシーラッサ
何も道徳のないパーパ・ダンマッサの悪にまみれているね
人にエーワ・ルーポー
このようなシーラ・サンニャマ
このような道徳的な落ち着きはバヴィッサ・ティーティ
あるでしょうかと あるんでしょうかねとかね
そんなにもあり得るんでしょうかと
王様は信じません テーナ・コーパナ・サマエーナ・アーヤスマ・アングリマーラ・バガトー・アヴィドーレー・ニシンノーホーティ
テーナコーパナサメン
その時 アーヤスマングリマール
アングリマール尊者が
バゴとアビドゥ お釈迦様のそばに
二神の座ってるんですね
まあ横にそこら辺で座ってるんです
アタコーバガダーヒナバハンパッガヘットワーラージャナンパセーナディンコーサランヘタドボーチャ
その時 お釈迦様が右腕を握って
それ王の右腕なんですね
王の手を握ったんです
なかなかすることではありません
お釈迦様みたいな人でないと
あの王様や触ったりする
触ったりすることはすぐできませんし
だからお釈迦様には まあインドの宗教世界ではもうかなり社会通してもすごい立場がありましたからね
シャカ族の王でしたから
で 出家したって王たちはその家の家柄の尊敬はすごくありましたし
ですから王は普通同格で王たちとは喋ったりもする
ですから 何のことなく王様の右手を腕を捕まるんですね
ラッラッゴスローにこういうことを言うんですね
エーソーマハラジャアングリマール
王様の手を握って これアングリマールですと
そばにいる御坊さんを見せるんですね
アタコーランニョパセーナディッサコーサラッサアフデーヴァバヤン
それを見たところで カセオーサロ
オーサロー様がものすごく怖くなりましたと
アウチャンビタッタン
震え始めたんだと それは怖くなって怯えて震えたんですよ
アフルロマハンソー 毛が立ちましたと
あまりにも怖い人なんですよ
見たこともない 誰見たこともしょ
ものすごいどれほど怖かったというとね
それをお釈迦様は前もって知っているんだから
王様が怖くなると もう王様の立場がなくなっちゃうんですね
それで もう手を握って
腕で捕まって だからそれお釈迦様のすごいところなんですね
で いかに人のことを心配するかと
人の社会的な立場やら
もう何から何までものすごい心配するんですよ
だから王様 お釈迦様のことはものすごく尊敬しているんだから
お釈迦様に捕まれてる時はね
それほどありがたいことはその人にもないし
お釈迦様の心も一番偉大なる心ですからね
まあそれですぐ恐怖感というのはさっと消えてしまうんですよ
ですから 誰にも気づかないんです
ものすごくびっくりして硬直してしまっちゃって
でもまあお釈迦様に捕まってるんだから
まあすぐもう怖さがなくなりますね
アタコーバガワーラージャナンパセーナディンコーサラン
ビータンサンヴィッダロマハッタジャータンヴィディットワーラージャナンパセーナディンコーサランヘタドボーチャ
まあその時王様がものすごく怖くなったことは知って
こういうことを言います
マーバイマハラジャ まあ怖がる必要はないんだよと
マーバイマハラジャ ２
回も まあ怖がることも何もない
怖がらなくてもいいんだよと
ナッティテアトバヤン
あなたにはこれから何のも
その場合はバヤっていうのは怖いということなんですが
何の問題もありませんと
これからは まあこの人からは何も怖いといわゆる問題は起きませんと
ですから その時もマーバイマハラ
王様怖がるなよと言ったら怖がったことになるでしょうね
その時はこの言葉のニュアンスとしては
もう王様あなたではいいという意味じゃないんです
王様が怖がる必要はありませんと
もうこれからあなたには何の問題もないんだと
こいつからはという という場合は
王様と言えば もう国を通してこの国には何の問題もないという意味で
だから聞いてる人々は王様が怖く
怖くなったっていうことは全く気にしないんですよ
同じ言葉使ってるんだけど
もうだから個人を呼ぶ時もタイトルを呼ぶ時もありますからね
タイトルで呼ぶ場合は個人ではありません
総理とか大統領と言えば個人ではありません
ですから 個人も呼べますよ
大統領座ってくださいと言ったら
まあある人間に座ってくださいと言うんですね
ですから この言葉の使い方によって個人を呼ぶか
もう公人を呼ぶかという
まあニュアンスがあるんですね
だから２回目 お釈迦様
本当は王様に怖がらないと言ってるんですけど
その時はやっぱりニュアンスとしては公人を呼んでいるような感じで話してるんですね
いわゆる国に喋ってるんですね
ああ もう怖がらなくてもいいやと
バエ バエにならなくてもいいんだと
もうこれからは何のバエもないんだと
まあバエ  アタコーランヨ
パセエナディッサコウソラッサヤンアホウシバヤンチャンビットワチャンビタッタワローマハンソワアソパティッパッサンビ
そこで王様にはお釈迦様に約束されちゃったんだから
ヤンアホウシバヤンワチャンビタッタワが何か怖いことが何かもう怯えることがあったならば
それは全部パティッパッサンビ
なくなってしまった なんのことなく心がもう王に戻ってしまったんですね
アタ
コーラージャーパセエナディコウソローエーナアヤスマアンゴリマーローテーヌパサンカミウパサンカミットアアヤスマンタンアンゴリマーランエタダウォーチャー
そこで王様が何のことなくアンゴリマーラ存じ上げるところに行って
アンゴリマーラ尊者にこう言うんですね
アイヨーノーバンテーアンゴリマーローティ
まず確認する アイヨーっていうのは目上の人を呼ぶ時のパーリの言葉なんですね
まあ今日本語の言葉ないんですからね
まあ先生みたいな言葉なんですね
英語ではサーと呼ぶんですよ
サー サーっていうのはすごい目上の人を呼ぶ言葉なんですね
英語で大丈夫 イギリスの英語で
アメリカ英語でもあまり言葉はないんですね
ただミスターだけなんですけどね
それはそんな敬語ではありません
イギリス英語ではものすごいたくさんの敬語
すごいたくさんあります
その人の立場によっていろいろ敬語を使います
とにかく女王からこの何とか勲章と何とか言うんでしょうかね
そういうものをもらっている人々はみんなサーなんですね
だから名前の前にミスターとか書かないんです
ミスター取り消して SIR 書くんですね
それは決まりで ですから
その人を呼ぶ時もサーという言葉でサーという言葉で呼ぶんです
で もっと権力ある人々にはまた違う違う言葉がありますね
例えば女王と話す場合は Your Majesty と喋らなくちゃいけない
ユーとは言わないんです
で アメリカ英語ではないんですけど
Your Majesty いつでもそのセットで読むんですよ
例えば入りません いつでも You Your
代わりに人をあなたという場合は
いつでも Your Majesty
それから皇太子には別にあります
で Your Royal Highness だと思いますけどね
で 同じ敬語 HRH は あの
何でしたっけ コンソート名
女王の フィリップっていう旦那さんがいるんですね
彼にも HRH ってタイトル使うしね
それはほとんど HRH
何でしたっけ？ HMS とかね
大文字でテンテンテン入れて書きますからね
それでアイヨーノーバンテーアンゴリマーロー
王様は大変敬語を使っていて
王様は自分より目上の人に使う言葉ですよ
で アンゴリマーラですかと
先生はアンゴリマーラと言いますかと
ですかと聞いたら エワンマハラで
はい そうですと  カタンゴット
ちょっと法律的に調べるんですね
ゴットゴートラは何ですか？いわゆる家は何ですかと
カタンゴットバンテアイアッサピタ
カタンゴッタマータ アイアッサ先生のピタ
父親が何家ですかと それでカタンゴッタマータ
母親がどんな家の人ですか
いわゆるファミリーネームを聞くんですね
ガッゴウコマーラージャピタ
父親はガッガと呼んだよと
マンターニマータと 母の名前はマンターニですと
アビラマトバンテアイヨウガッゴウマンターニプット
それはもう正式な名前なんですね
アンゴリマーラの アンゴリマーラお坊さんの正式な名前は一応ガッゴウマンターニプット
アビラマト喜んでくださいと
このやりとりは一つの法律みたいな決まりのやりとりで
普通だったらお坊さんですか
じゃあ何かあったら言ってくださいということで終わりますけど
やっぱりこの人は犯罪者だから
王様がやっぱり審判をして判決を出さなくちゃいけないし
だから王はどこにいても国だから
どこで何喋ったっても法律でしょうし
ですから その場でさっさっと形式的に君の名前なんですかとかね
ということで 家は何ですかとか
そういう風に個人を確認して
それで判決を出すんですよ
王様の判決ですね アビラマトバンテアイヨウガッゴウマンターニプット
バンテっていうのは尊辞ということで尊辞
またアイヨウマンターニプット
マンターニプッタという先生ですね
師ですね 師みたいかな
まあいいや まあ訳すればそれですけどね
ミステの代わりに使うことで
ことでね ですから その時は妻家の名前を使って判決出すんですね
ガッゴウマンターニプッタという
では喜んでくださいと
アハンアイアッサガッガッサマンターニプッタッサウッスッカンカリッサーミ
私はガッガマンターニプッタという先生に対してウッスッカン
まあ一応努力しますと
頑張ってみますといわゆる気になりますというか
付添を任せてくださいという意味なんですね
それを私が責任持ちますと
私が責任持りますと 何のこと対してかというと
チーワラピンダパートセーナースナギラナパッチベーサジャパリッカーリ
必要な生活費については
私は責任持ちますと あなたはもう喜んでくださいと
アビラマトということは
喜びなさいという意味なんですけど
自分の活動をしっかりやってくださいということなんですね
だいたい じゃあもう頑張ってくださいという場合は
パーリ語だったらアビラマトということなんですね
いわゆる自分の仕事を続けてやってください
それをパーリ語で言いたければ
アビラマト喜びなさいと
インド人は頑張らないみたいですね
やっぱり仕事をすると
やっぱり神経質になってヒステリーを起こして体壊してやるのはすごいかっこいいと思ってはいるんですけど
向こうはそうじゃなくて
自分の専職を大変喜んで楽しくやるというプライドを持って
そういう意味でこういう言葉を使っているんですよ
それは本当はどんな仕事にしたってやるやり方なんですよ
自分やる仕事について満足を得て
喜んで プライドを持って楽しみながらやらないとやりきれないんですけどね
ですから 頑張るっていうのはね
あんまりいい言葉ではないんですけど
晴ることだからね まあ日本語だったら頑張ってくださいって意味な訳は頑張る頑張ってくださいという訳なんですけど
私は言っているのは頑張るという言葉の意味の中では
しがみついて 神経質で
必死で 歯を噛んで踏ん張るという意味があるんだということなんです
でも 自分の専門分野であるならば
自分の専属であるならば
そんなに歯を噛んで踏ん張らなくても気持ちよく気楽にできるはずなんです
テーナコーパナサメーナアヤスマアンゴリマーラアーランニャコーホーティピンドパティコーパンスクーリコーテーチービリコー
それでアンゴリマール尊者がその時は特別戒律をいくつか受けているんです
普通のお坊さんの戒律ではなくて
もっと特別な戒律もいくつか須陀洹入るものですけど
受けているんですね 一つはアーランニャコ
アランヤで森の方で生活する人の限界やらそこら辺に来ない
作っているお寺とかね
そこら辺では生活しない
森の中でどこかで一人で生活するという
人が出入りする場所には生活しないということ
ヒンデバーティコ それから人の接待は受けない
来てください頼んでも受けないという戒律を守っている
ですから 托鉢だけで生活する
明日ご飯用意しておきますから
お布施に来てくださいと言ったら受け取りません
行かない どこかで托鉢に行くんです
そういう戒律 それからパンスクーリコ
捨てた布を拾って衣を作って着ますと
紛争へですね  まあ衣にはいつでも紛争へと言うんですけど
本当の紛争へなんです
いわゆるこの信者さんが服なんか布なんか持ってきても
それはいただかない その場合はいいものを持ってきますけど
とにかくあっちこっちで捨ててるものを探して
それで衣を作って着るという決まりですね
そのテーチーウィルコ
それも一つなんですね
まあ衣は三枚以上は全く持たないと
アタコーアヤスマアンゴニマーローラージャナンパセーナジンコーサランエタドーチェアランマハラジャパリプンナンメーテーチーワラン
で 王様にこう言うんです
アランマハラジャ 結構です
大王 結構ですと パリプンナンもう完璧にあるっていう意味で
まあ全部まあ間に合ってますと
チチーワラン サンゲはもうありますと
アタコーラジャパセーナディコーサロージェーナバガワーテーヌパサンカミパサンカミンターバガワンタンアビワディトゥワーエーカマンタンニシーディ
王様がもう一回 もうまた普通の人間に戻って
お釈迦様のところにまた行って
お釈迦様に礼をして また座る
だから 瞬時に役が変わるんですよ
ものすごい速いスピードで
王様が人間としてお釈迦様のところに来て
礼をして もうお釈迦様にちょっとからかわれて
もうなんだあんたの態度とかね
誰かあなた怒っているんでしょうかって
ちょっとからかってるんですよ
戦争に出ていく状態だから
そしたらそうじゃないと言ったらアングリマーのことああそうですかと言って
もう何のことなく手を手を捕まって
これがアングリマーですよと見せるし
王様がすごく怖くなっちゃうと
その瞬時にお釈迦様が個人ではなくて国王にしゃべる
あなたにとっては何の問題はこれからは無いんだと
この人からは それで王様が瞬時に国王として立ち上がってアングリマーと質問するんですね
それはもう審判なんですね
国王だから国王が無罪だとしておかないと
犯罪者でずっと犯罪者になっちゃうんですね
だから国王がその場で彼を罪からね
もう関係ないと無罪にしてあげるんですね
その時は国王としてしゃべるんですね
だから名前聞いていろいろ聞いて
お釈迦様アングリマーって言ったらそれだけで十分ですけど
それで法律はそう重くいきませんね
ですから まあそれでちゃんと審議を行って
無罪に して自分が守ってあげると
いわゆる自分がこの在家の信者さんとして
この面倒見る責任まで自分で受け取ると
お商人ですね お商人ですけど
出家の場合は時々信者さんが在家の人々はそうやって
ミャンマーの場合は確実に出ます
どんなお坊さんにも一人在家の人が全面的に協力して守ってあげる人っていうのはいるんです
その人がいないと 比丘戒はあまり行わないんですね
別に法律 戒律ではないんだけど
やっぱりお坊さんたちにお布施をして
礼をして その自分がそこどこかで座って
この自分がお商人ではなくて
面倒見てあげるんだという面倒見役なんですね
うん だから何か問題があったら
何か困ったことがあったら
お坊さんたちは困らなくてもよろしいし
その在家の人はそれを全部用意すると
例えば病気になったりすると
もうそのお坊さんがその人に言えばいいんです
自分を守ってくれる人だからね
で そう言われると その人は用意してあげたりするというような
まあ今もその仕来りはあります
それ審判が終わってから
またお釈迦様のところに来て
またお釈迦に礼をして
また普通にお坊様が話を続けていくんですね
バグアンタンエタドゥアチャ
お釈迦様にこのことを言う
アッチェリアンバンテアッブタンバンテ
アッチェリアンバンテ
まあ不可思議ということですね
まあ考えられないんだと
アッブタンバンテ ありえない話だと
これなんか読みにくい感じ
日本語の言葉あるみたいですけど
ケウ ケウはアッブタっていうことですね
アッチェリアにはケウとミゾウ
ミゾウと まあ普通の日本語でこちらで言ってるように
まあまあまあ珍しいことですよっていうんですけどね
まあこれはものすごいまあ奇跡だよということなんです
ヤーワンチダンバンテバガワンバガワアダンターナンダメータ
アサンターナンサメータ
アパリニッブターナンパリニッバーペータ
お釈迦様のことになると
もうもう信じられないんだと
もうありえないことばっかり起こるんだよと
で どういうことかというと
アダンターナンダメータ
もう管理できない もうなんか野生みたいな生活はもうアダンタっていうことで
そういう人々は何のことなくきちんと行儀の良い人間にしてあげる
アサンターナンサメータ
アサンタっていうのは
何のも平安な生き方をしない
いわゆる平和的な生き方をしない
もう乱暴者ですね そういう人々はサメータ
すっごい落ち着いて もう平安な人間にしちゃうんだと
アパリニッブターナン
まあこれは涅槃に関係ある言葉なんですけど
アパリニッブタっていうのはもう燃えている状態ですね
もうあらゆることで精神的にもう燃えて燃えて悩んでいる人々の場合は
パリニッバーペータ 全部あの火を消すんだと
お釈迦様は だからそれはまあ涅槃のことでもありますね
こんなのはもう信じられませんと
それほど不思議でたまらないんだと
だからいつでもそういうことをやってるんだから
どういうことでしょうかっていう
王様が大変まあ喜びますね
ヤンヒマヤンバンテナサッキンハダンデーナピサッテーナピダメート
私の場合はダンデーナというのはこの罰を与えることですね
サッタっていうのはもう武器ですね
だから まあそれは法律的なこと
ダンダっていうのはもうパニッシュメントであって
この刑務所に入れるとか
縛っておくとか あるいはもう殴ったり
鞭で打ったりとかね まあそういう罰のことはダンデで
で 次は何でしたっけ サッタっていうのはやっぱり武器であって
刃物だから 昔だからまあ刀でしょうしね
まあそれでやっちゃってもということで
いわゆる足を切って捨てるか
手を切って捨てるか 首を切って捨てるかというふうな罰はサッタですね
そういうことをやっても
ナーサッキンハダメート
人々を管理することはできないんだと
いわゆるもう人間っていうのはもういい加減ですごい法律を犯して
もう悪いことばっかりやってるんですけど
それでお坊様が刑務所に入れるわ
もう何年も縛ってる状態にしておくわ
また手を切ったり 足を切ったり
首を切ったりもするわ
もうそれでもやってるんだと
それほどすごいひどいことをしているのにも
自分にはできないことだよ
これは そのバガワ そのそのお釈迦様がアダンレーナ
何も罰はない アサッテーナ
何も武器も何もない かすかにでも人に罰を与えることも脅すこともない
ええわ 何ど なのにみんな落ち着いてもらっちゃいますと
それでお釈迦様にことをそうやって驚いちゃって
ハンダダーニマヤンバンテーガッチャーム
では私は帰りますと バフキッチャーマヤンバフカラニア
いろいろお仕事ありますよと
ヤッサダーニトワンマハラジャカーランマンニャシー
まああんたもいいでしょうと
アタコーラージャーパセーニディコーサラウッターヤースナーバガワンタンアビワーデッターパダッキナンカッターパッカーム
お釈迦様に礼をして 回って礼をして帰っちゃうんですね
とにかくお釈迦様が一応アングリマーラというもう人間の社会に入れることはできない人を出家したんだけど
させたんだけど 逆に責任あるんだよ
お釈迦様は お釈迦様はその人の命をちゃんと守ってあげちゃったんですね
だから ただ無責任の じゃあ解脱しなさいとか
出家しなさい 私は何も知らんぞという感じではないんですよ
やっぱりすごい心配するというか
必要なことはちゃんと手を打つ
お坊さん 誰かがちょっと病気だなと分かったら
なんとか手を打つんですよ
で 彼にその病気を治すように
そういう治療を受けるように
どこかにとにかくそういうそこら辺の手を打っておく
修行でもなんかちょっとうまくいかないんだったら
それはどういうことかと見て
すぐそれを手を打ってみる
で 時々修行するんだぞと言ったっても
ちょっとやめなさいよという場合もあります
その時でも その人にとっては時期ではありませんしね
ですから あらゆる面で
もう完全にお釈迦様に弟子入り
弟子入りした人の面倒っていうのはもう完全に見るんですね
だからブッダのところに行った人っていうのは
もうそれほど安らぎられるとこはないんですよ
だから誰でもブッダに帰依したら
もうそれだけでもうえらい元気で
何の心配することもなく
地獄の心配もないし 何も心配はないと
それだけでものすごい安心するんです
実際にお釈迦様がやっぱりそういうふうな行為をなさっているんですね
ですから お釈迦様が人を追い出しちゃったら
追い出される人は全然文句言わないで
礼をしてわかりましたと帰りますよ
だから もしお釈迦様に追い出されたっても
それこそその人に対しては一番いいことということは知ってます
相手側も 私のところから出て行きなさいと
そしたら はい わかりましたと
それもありがたく受けて出て行っちゃうんですね
ブッダってブッダと言いながら何をということはないんです
その一言言ったら その人はそれでもう終わっちゃいますからね
すごい罪ですからね だから
かねでもお釈迦様に対してはやっぱり失礼なことっていうのはとんでもないことなんですよ
こういう存在はもう現れませんだからね
はい
次に行きます アトコーアヤスマアンゴリマーロープッバンナサミャンニワセッターパッタジーバランアーダーエサーヴァッティンピンダーエパーヴィシーアンゴリマーラソンジャガー
マー
ご先祖サーサーヴァッティ町で托鉢に出かけます
アッダサコーアヤスマアンゴリマーローサーヴァッティャンサパダーナンピンダーチャラーマーノーアニャタランイッティンムーラガッバンヴィサータガッバン
で アッダサミマスタトアンゴリマーラソンジャガ
こう サーヴァッティャンサパダーナンピンダーエチャラーマーノー
サパダーナっていうのは
この家から家っていう意味で
いわゆる家を飛ばさないんですね
ある街に入ったら その各家を訪ねるんです
それで行く時はアニャタランイッティン
ある女の人がムーラガッバン
何でしたっけ？難産で
ヴィサータガッバン それおなじみなんですね
楽じゃないと で いわゆる子供は出てこないんですね
ディッスワーナッサエータダホーシ
それ見たらこういう考え方が生まれたんだと
キリッサンテワタボーサッタ
人々はものすごく苦労しているんでしょうと
すごい慈しみが 憐れみが生まれてくるんです
今までまるっきりなかった
あれほど酷いことをしたのに
もう今はあれ ああいう痛みを見ていられないんですね
すごいもう見ていられなくなっちゃったんですね
あの女性の苦しみを キリッサンテワタボーサッタ
それはもう もう感情を伸ばしてるんですね
なんということか 人々はどれほど苦しんでいるんでしょうか
どれほど苦しんでいるんでしょうかと自分に言い返しちゃうんですね
アトコーアヤスマアンゴリマーローサーヴァッティャンピンダーチャリッターパッチャーバッタンピンダパートパティッカントイェナバグワーテーヌプサンカミ
それで食事終わって お釈迦様のところにまた行くんですね
ウパサンカミッタバガワンタンアビワデットワエーカマンサンニ
それでまあお釈迦様に礼をして座ります
エーカマンサンニシッノーコーアヤスマアンゴリマーローバガワンタンエータダボーチャ
お釈迦様にこういうことを言います
イダ
ハンバンテープッバンナサミャンニワセットワッパッタジーバランアーダーエサーヴァッティンピンダーエパーヴィシンアッダサンコーアハンバンテーサーヴァッティャ
ンサパダーナンピンダーチャラーマーノーアニャタランイッティンムーラガッバンヴィサータガッバンディッスワナメエータダホーシキリッサンテワタボーサッタキリッサンテワタボーサッタアティ
そのエピソードを全部言うんですね
私は托鉢している時は
まあこういうある女の人がいましたと
で 難産でしたと で 苦しんでいるのをそれ見た私は
なんで人々は苦しんでいるんでしょうか
なんで人々は苦しんでいるんでしょうかという考え方が生まれてきたんだ
生まれたんだと そこでお釈迦様は何か解決を教えるんですね
テーナヒ であるならばということ
だったらこんなことをやりなさい
テーナヒトワナアンゴリマーラ
だったらアンゴリマーラ
イェナサーヴァッティテーヌプサンカミ
このサーヴァッティのその場所に行きなさいよと
プサンカミッタタンイッティンエータダオーチャ
エータンワデーヒ あんた
その女のところに行きなさい
行ってこういうことを言いなさいよと
だからまあ やっぱりそれも普通の世俗的なことなんですけど
それでもお釈迦様が何とかしてあげることはあればしてあげるんだということなんです
こういうことを言いなさい
ヤトアハンバギニ ジャーと
バギニっていうのは女の女性を呼ぶ言葉なんで
娘 妹って意味なんです
で 女の人を呼ぶ場合はバギニという言葉で呼ぶんです
ですから どんな日本語はないんですけどね
まあお嬢さんはちょっとやりすぎし
妹 まあお姉さんみたいな
ついたってもね まあバギニっていうのは妹だから
年下だから まあ失礼じゃない
すごい可愛いという意味は入ってます
お姉さん 日本語だったらお姉さんとは言いますけどね
そんなに可愛いという感じが入ってないんですけどね
こちらどんな訳でしたっけ？ああ
婦人よ うん 頑張ったでしょうね
何言葉選ぼうと [笑い]で
バギニは一応妹って意味なんです
いわゆる姉弟 呼ぶ兄弟ですね
まあ姉弟呼ぶ言葉で呼ぶんです
私たちはやっぱり女性はみんな誰でもまあ妹と呼ぶんです
女性喜びますから 妹というと自分より年下だから
[笑い]お姉ちゃんというよりは
でもあるし そう呼ばれた瞬間にすごく安心するんですね
女性の方も 何もこの人からは何のも
この人に対しては警戒する必要も何もないんだと
姉弟という呼び方だから
まあもうだったら まあなんていうんですか
姉という 兄貴という感じが生まれてきますね
それですごい気楽に話をする
気に入ってる女の人にはもう妹とは呼ばないんで
そうするとそれはまずくなってしまっちゃいます
関係が すごいその言葉だけでえらい心の態度っていうのはえらく変わるんですよ
名前で呼んだりすると
まあ異性として扱ってるんだっていうことはすぐわかる
そうすると女性もそれなりに警戒する
名前で呼んだら男はやっぱりもう一応
何て言いますか この何て言いますか
男に話しかけることは何とか言いますけどね
なんて言います？女の人に男が話しかけてくることには
ナンパですね で まあバギニーと言えば
その気持ちは全くはないんですね
ですから もうバギニーという言葉で言われると
全然女性はもう全然警戒とも何ともなく話したりする
ですから ちょっと言葉だけでもかなり人間の気持ちっていうのは変わるんです
それはどうでも関係ない話で
夫人業と こういう やっとアハンジャート
私は生まれてからナビジャナメというのは知りませんという
で 次は続きますが やったことは知りませんと
これやったことはないって意味なんで
サンチッチ 自分の意思でわざわざと
パーナンジータウォローペタ
生命を殺したことはないと
私がわざわざと自分の意思で
意思で生命を殺したことなんかは知りませんと
生まれてから そういうふうに言いなさいと
テーナサッチーナソッティーテーホーと
その真理の力で力っていうのは入りませんだけど
パーリ語でとは入れません
その真理の力でソッティテーホーとあなたに幸福がありますようにと
ソッティガッバッサ 胎児にも幸福がありますようにと
で これはこの仏教の世界では
この人々に祝福するのをする論理体系ですよ
だからこの真理の力で祝福するんだと
だから言ってることは真理であるならば
確実に幸福になるんだという設定なんです
だから経典の意味なんかわかるんだったら
聞いてもらう人々はもうほとんど百パーセント聞きます
聞いてない人っていうのはいません
かすかにでも失礼な態度取っちゃうと何の効き目もない
我々そっちをお経をあげたりしますから
それはすぐ分かります
これは無駄だと この連中にあたっても効き目がないと
すごく嫌なんで その時は
途中でやめたくなりますから
仕事だからね 途中でやめるわけにはいきませんし
それでも関係ない話で
もうもう見てないふりをして
とにかくもう頑張るんです
その時は お経あげる時は
頑張ってお経上げて祝福して帰りますけど
ストレスも溜まります
相手はそういう失礼な態度取らないで
本当にありがたいという
聞いてると全然ストレスは溜まりません
その場では効きます すぐ時間経ちません
そこら辺になってくるとなんとなく密教的
だから密教を広げたのはそれぐらいのポイントなんですよ
真言という言葉でしょうね
真言密教でしょ たったその一言葉で一つの宗派ができちゃって
仏教潰すところまで発展しているんですよ
真言です サッチャワッジャっていうのは
日本語で直訳すると真言です
真実の言葉という これはもう別に仏教の本職ではありません
ただ そこら辺人が苦しんでいると
見て見ぬふりすることはできません
だから 自分たちは本当は力持ってますが
そういうやたらにはやりませんし
その時はなんとかしてあげる
時々 最近人に出会う場がないんですけど
あっちこっち行く時はもう日本の中でも
もうこれはもう遺伝かもしれませんし
過去生かもしれませんし
突然私なんか子供見た瞬間で来て
子供でも触らせてくださいとかね
それはわかります その人はもうなんとか苦しんでいるんだよと
そこでまあもうたった 1 秒で祝福するんです
それでまあ効きます 相手もそれなりの気持ちは持っているし
まあそういうこの現世利益の仕事っていうのは
バラモン人の仕事でしたからね
それは仏教はもう反対でそんなもういろいろ神々にいろんなお祈りしたりしたってもね
効くわけでもないし それはまああんまり仏教は気にしてないんですけど
仏教の仏教徒の場合ですね
やっぱり仲間同士でちょっとトラブっちゃうと
別な宗教の神様にお祈りするわけにはいきませんし
仏教では神っていうのはあまりお祈りする対象でもないし
神々はいることは普通お釈迦様の教えからまあまあ認めてはいるんだけど
だからといって信仰したりお祈りしたりすることはしません
その代わりにこうすることをするんだからね
で 守りたければ勝手に守りなさいという態度を取っちゃうんですね
あんまりこの身分低い態度は取りません
神々に対しては で 戒律を守っていない人にとっては何の力もないんですけど
ほとんどみんな五戒守っていたんだから
五戒守るんだったらかなり力があるんですよ
精神的には ですから 身分低いわけじゃないんです
神々よりは ですから 戒律を五戒守っている人は
もう神々に回向なんかしてくれると
もう自分 神々の方が勝手に守ってくれるんだと
何かあったら自分で出て出てきて
こうしなさい ああしなさいと教えてくれたりするっていうのは
そういうのはそこら辺で我々のミャンマーであろうが
スリランカだろうが ごく普通の話で
みんな誰かに聞いたら
もう 10人聞いたら一人ぐらい二人ぐらい
そんなことは自分の経験で知ってるもんなんですよ
もう１万人に聞いた中で一人だけそんな話ではないんです
10人 15人聞いたら
そういえば私にこういうことありましたとかね
そういうのはまあまあしょっちゅうあることで
一応悪いことしている人にとっては
もう全く効き目がないんです
だから五戒守ることは
最近の人々はそれはもうもう決まりで
五戒は守ってほしいと
そうするともう直接来て
もう信仰じゃない もうはっきりとわかるように
じゃああんたそれは行くなよとかね
やめなさいとかね で それなんと例えば病気になって
どこか他の治療に行こうとしたら
それはやめて 他のところになんとか行ってくださいとかね
突然出てきて言ったりするとかね
よくある普通にあることでね
まあそれは神の関係になっちゃうとそういう話なんですけど
でも仏教の世界の中では
この真言で祝福するという
だから経は厳密にその
だから一番古いんです
一番というよりも この祝福する経典の中ですごく古くて
経典としてもものすごい古い経典なんですね
全部偈だけで終わってるしね
その中でずっとエテーナサッチェーナエテーナサッチェーナ
言はない その場合は この真理でこの真理でこの真理で
この上にあるのは全部真理なんですね
だから一つの嘘ではありません
で それでスワッティボーと
だからエテーナサッチェーナスワッティ
それだけで十分です だからこの御利益やらいろんなことに依存する人にとっては
もうなんかあまりもう束縛してないんではないかとと勘違いしたりする
その場合はあまりめんどくさいんですけど
仏教徒の中ではね すぐもう一言葉で瞬時に終わるんです
そういうふうに言いなさいと
生まれてからこの方は殺生したことはないんだと
その真理のこの言葉で
力であんたとあなたの子供が胎児が幸福でありますようにと言いなさいよと
そうしたらソウヒヌーナメバンテサンパジャナムサーワードバディッサティ
それがお釈迦様 私にとってはサンパジャナムサーワード
ものすごいもうわざと強引にじゃなくて
もうサンパジャナムサーワードというのははっきりと嘘であるということを知った上で嘘をついたことになります
わざとごまかして嘘をついたことになるんだと
知らないで言ったことは嘘っていうふうなことになりませんだからね
マヤーヒバンテバフサンチッチパナジービタボーロピタ
私は存じ ものたくさん生命を殺しましたと
これ生命じゃなく人間なんですけど
私はたくさんの人々を殺した人間だよと
こんなこと言ったら嘘もいいところになるんだよと
テーナヒトゥアンギュリ
それでお釈迦様またそれで改選するんですね
法律は だったらということで
それいつでもお釈迦様は使う手段なんですよ
2番目のことを言いたいんだから
前にわざとどうも有り得ないことを言うんですよ
それはよくお釈迦様使う手段です
テーナヒトゥアンギュリのはそれだったらアンギュリマーラ
イエナサーバティテーナウパサンカウパサンカミトアタンイッティンエワンマデ
だったらこういうもうこういうふうに言葉を言ってくださいと
ヤトアハンバギニアリアヤジャーティヤジャート
私はアリアジャーティというのはアリアっていうのはアーリア民族の言葉なんですけど
一応お釈迦様が優れた人々
善人とかね という意味で使ってますね
だから仏教もアリアダンマですね
アリアの教え  4つの真理もアリアサッチャなんですね
正体ですね だから今正しいという言葉で四聖諦の場合は
四聖諦の場合はどんな感じでしたっけ
聖人の聖だった  そうですか
そうですね だから聖人の感じ使うんですね
優れているという素晴らしい清らかなという意味で
だから清らかな世界でアリアヤジャーティ
生まれてからはアリアヤジャーティヤジャート
これは2番目の生まれなんですよ
この思考が仏教からかわかりませんだけど
キリスト教を使ってるんだから
学者がキリスト イエスというのはもう仏教ではないかと
あっちこっち行って仏教を学んで
あんな偉そうなことを自分の国で言ったんではない
言ってることはほとんど仏教の何も反対じゃないんだから
イエススが言った言葉はね
だから敵まで愛することやらね
何から何まで言って 神の概念での後からついたもんで
物語いっぱいつけちゃってね
後で一人になったんですけど
とにかくこの2番目に生まれるとという概念がイエススが作った概念なんですね
生まれ変わらなきゃ神の国には行けませんと
こちらでも新しい生まれなんですね
出家して仏道に入ることは
もうもとの人間ではありませんと
新しい新生児だよと そういう気持ちで生きなくちゃいけないので
一旦仏教徒になったら
自分が新世紀であることを考えて
もう過去のことはもう全部もう気にしないで
新しい人生 新しい生まれを頑張ればいいんです
ナビジャナミサンチッチャパーナンジーヴィタボーローペッタ
それからはもう聖人として
いわゆる聖なる世界で生まれてからは
私は殺生したことはありませんと
テーナサッチャーナソティテーホトソッティガッバッサーティ
その真理の力であなたとあなたの胎児に幸福でありますように
エーワンバンテーティコワーヤスマングリマールバゴートゥパティスットアエーナサワエーテーヌプサンカーミサッサットお釈迦様
アングリマーラ尊者がその女の人がいるところに行くんです
ウパサンカミトアタンイッティニエタドーティ
その女にこういうことを言います
ヤトーアハンバギニアリアジャートゥジャート
女の前にいて あのお釈迦様が言っちゃった通りにあの行を言うんですよ
私はもう聖人として いわゆる聖なる世界で生まれてからは一度も殺生したことはない
テーナサッチャーナこの真理の力で
ソッティテーホトソッティガッバッサーティ
あなたとあなたの胎児に幸福がありますように
アタコソッティイッティヤホソッティガッバッサ
それであの女の人も大変楽になって
ソッティっていうのは病気が治ったって意味なんです
ソッティっていうのはいろいろ意味で使いますが
普通にソッティテーホトといえば幸福でありますようにという意味なんですけど
病気が治ることもソッティという言葉を使うんですね
ですから そこでそういうことでその言葉使ってます
だから今日出てくるスワッティというのも
スカンガッティという風なスワッティというソッティなんです
それも それであの二人が治りましたと
で かなりこのアングリマーラ尊者のこと
ここでハイライトするんですよ
だから人間でたくさん人を殺したのにも関わらず
一旦戒律を守ることをしたならば
それだけでこれぐらいの力が入りましたっていうことなんです
たった一言葉で人の病気まで治してあげるぐらいのすごい力が入りましたと
ですから ちゃんとした人間で生きてみなさいよと思う
これはもうどれほど価値があるすごいことかとわかる
わかるんですか？か？というふうなことなんです
こちらですごく軽々しく滑らかに言っているのは
戒律ぐらいで守ってみなさいよと
こちらでもうアングリマーラ尊者のすべての戒律のことさえも入ってないんですよ
ただ 殺生か一つの戒律だけなんですね
その呪文に使っているのは
呪文じゃないんだけど
その心言に使っているのは
たった一つの戒律なんです
ですから 人間は余計に苦しむ必要はないんだよと
いい加減でも乱暴で 野生動物みたいな生き方をしているんですから
それはちょっとやめてみなさいと
簡単単純でしょう それだけでどれほど幸福になるかと
例えば国一つしたっても
人口の半分ぐらいでも戒律を一つぐらいで守っているんだ
それ頼れません その国は経済的に全くものすごく豊かになるんです
自然みるみるうちに変わるんです
だからそれは不可思議
誰が信じるもんか そんなこと言える立場ですかね
野生動物でいて 物事を判断できるんですかねと
こちら聞きたいんですよ
何一つも道徳は守ったことはないし
親を尊敬したことがないし
目上の人を尊敬したことがないし
もう動物の生き方でしょ
現代世界でね 経済ばっかしで欲ばりだけの生きている世界っていうのは
金だったら親もないし子供もないし
もう何でもやっつけちゃうし
殺しちゃうしね そこが科学的で現代的で進歩世界だと言いながらね
こういう話を言っちゃうと
なんだアホの話やとか言いますけど
そうではないんですけどね
自分の国にもこのテロ活動が起きたのは
この前のラジャパクサという大統領がこの法律を犯して大統領になっちゃって
法律を犯して国会議員を回に伸ばして
強引で全部民主主義で
なんでもない民主主義は一かけらもない
憲法も作ってね 全ての権力を自分で握っちゃった
握って 同時に国民はもう民主主義に慣れてたんだからね
暴動したり喧嘩したりするで
それでやったのは もういきなり国の国を解放しちゃったんですね
いきなり日にしてアメリカ主義にしちゃったんです
儲かりたい放題儲かりなさいと
見ませんと自分たちは管理もしません
だから全て何て言いますか
この規制っていうのはね
一切全部取り消し 一日で
だから何でも輸入したいものは何でも輸入できるとかね
もう何て言います 輸出できる
何でも勝手に だからみんな金金金だけでもういきなりもう
一日 二日 三日でもう国がもう変わってしまったんですね
そこである人が私はバス停で会って話した
その人は一生 そのずっともうすごい激しい人でも
その大統領の党を応援している人なんですね
で だからあまりも力強くで法律ももう変えちゃってね
もう喋ったら殺されるぐらいになってしまって
で その人さえもこれがやばいと
バス停で私にもう初めて言うんですね
もうその法律を決めても 1週間も経ってないんですね
こんなことになったら
この国がもう終わりですねとか
何が終わりですかと だってみんな道徳とかね
今まで持ってきた価値観とかね
全てなくなるんだと 経済成長良くないという意味じゃないんです
全てなくなるんだと 私は心の中でそのそれはもうそれは分かっているんだけど
お前らではないかという態度でね
決めたのは そうですかと
それで終わっちゃったんですけど
話は で 自分が引っかかることは言いません
で でも確かに結局経済成長したんではなくて
まあ半年も経たないうちに
もうずっと仲良くしていたタミル人たちが
いきなりもう人殺し始めるんですね
それからずっと今までもやっている
何万人人が死んだんでしょうかね
ほとんどまあ七 八万人も死んでいると思いますよ
だからどこでも人は死ぬ
死ぬ 死ぬ 殺すは殺されるはもう終わりがないんですね
だからすごいもうヤクザではなくて
このマフィアみたいな
もうガンいくらでもいます
ちょっとお金払えばすぐ人を殺してくるという
全てもうそれからもうじきに雨も降らないし
国はもう緑一色でしたんだけど
今はブラウン色一色で
木は育てられないし 花は咲かないし
動物は見えませんし すごく寂しいんですよ
もう僕はどこかでもちょっと腰を掛けて座っていると
もう結構もう自分の庭
もうどこでもいいんですよ
もういろいろ小さな小さな動物たちがあっち行ったり
こっち小さなトカゲやらちょっと大きいトカゲの種類やら
もっと大きいトカゲもいるんですけど
すごい何のことはない
我が家のようにコソコソとやって歩いたりとかね
すっごいもう気持ちいいというと
あっちこっち鳥たちかけたら
もう自分の家であろうとも関係なく
そこら辺に窓なんか開けて
そちらに座りたいからそれで勝手に座ったりして
もう羽やらちょっとおしゃれをちょっとしてまた逃げたりするしね
なんか我が家の感じで
もう世界は私のものだという
それこの雰囲気っていうのはね
みんな一緒に仲良く だから迷惑はないんですよ
高い だから日本だったらカラスってすごい嫌がるでしょうね
もうカラスと台所の方っていうのはもうなんか一緒なもんですよ
スリランカの場合は そこら辺にずっと待ってずっと待っているんですね
何かもうだから見たら
家に何か食べ物あったら必ずあげる
よく見たんです 昔の世界
時代のこと言ってますからね
そうやって あの 何て言いますか
システムキッチンとかあるわけじゃないし
今もほとんどないんですけど
そこで あの 水筒で水を持って外へ行って
台所から外で そこで地面のところでね
で あの皿やら食器洗ってるでしょうね
洗ってそこら何のことなくカラスたちが何匹ぐらいね
お母さんたちと待ってるんですね
だから手を伸ばしたら
その手が触れますよ 全然もう何もお互いに誰も警戒しません
じゃあ何か食べ物なんか干したりするともう怒るんですけどね
もう持っていくなよとかね
ちょっと目が離したら持っていっちゃいますからね
まあいろいろ干す食べ物もありますからね
その代わりはもう文句言いながら守っているんです
カラスに持っていかれる
持っていかれちゃうしね
持っていってもあんまり気にしない
もう例えば あの米やらね
もの干したりする時とかね
それで一口持っていったんだからって言って
別にどうってことはないし
かえってあの持っていく持ち方見てるともうすごい可愛いんですね
全然警戒することでもなく
まあなんか自分の家の子供が
この 何て言いますか すぐ手を出して何か食べちゃうでしょ
あげる前に そんな顔なんですね
顔を横にして 横にしたらたくさん取れるんですよ
顔を横にして いっぱい米いっぱい取って
で 持っていく だから まあそういう雰囲気とかね
もうまるっきりもうほとんどないんですね
どこへ行ったかと だからやっぱり道徳が失ったら全部失うということなんです
それは経済学とは全く関係ない
だったら凶暴な軍事力やら
あらゆるこのもう凶暴的な行為で
騙し行為で金儲けなくちゃいけないんですね
だから西洋型の経済っていうのは
やっぱり まあ強引で まあ力ある人は儲かるとやり方ですよ
だからそういう風な儲かるかもしれませんだけど
同時に不安ですよ ものすごい心配で生きていられない状態にもなってくるんですね
だから 彼らがテロたちを作るんですよ
ですから 本当に道徳的な生き方だったらテロは作れないし
もう動物さえも随分仲良く一緒にいてくれる世界なんですけど
だから まあ仏教はまあ簡単単純なことでしょうに
何かちょっと戒律ぐらい守って道徳的に生きていれば誰にも迷惑ないでしょうに
なんでそれはそんなに嫌がるんですかと
嫌がるは 煙たがるは すごい軽視するは
酔っ払って悪いことやるとすごくもうかっこいい
かっこいいというね だからそういう好み出てくると
もう人類のもう破滅ということなんです
だから良いことよりは悪いことというのは簡単に広がりますからね
それはもうそれ一つの決まりなんですよ
健康な食べ物を食べて健康になるといえば
これ何年もかかりますよ
一つウイルスなんか広げる場合は
どれぐらいかかりますかね
二 三週間で十分だから
全国に広げるまで だから悪いことはものすごい早く広がりますし
ですから こちらでこの仏教の言い方というのはすごく優しくて言いますから
ものすごい優しく言ってるだけのことで
あの まあ道徳ぐらい守ってみなさいと
あのアンゴリマーラさんにしたっても
あれほど人を殺した人であっても
これぐらい奇跡的な能力を持ったんだよ
ただちょっとした戒律を守っただけで
阿羅漢になっただけ使ってないんですよ
わざと ものすごい戒律を守っていますけど
アンゴリマーラさんじゃが
それ一つのすごい たった一行で
一行の力で あの 死にかけている人はすぐたちまち治してみせると
アタ
コーアヤスマアンゴリマーローエコーウパカットアプマットアータピーパヒタットヴィヘラントーナチラスセーヤッサッタエコロプッタサッマデーヴァガーラスマナガー
リャンパッバジャンティッパダヌッタラムブラフマチャリーヤパリオサーナンディッテーワダンメーサヤンアヴィンニャーサッチカッターウパサンパッダヴィパーシー
それマテーケーモンクデアンゴリマーラソンジャガ一人で修行して
あの出家の目的に達しましたと
阿羅漢になりましたと
キーナージャータウシタンブラフマチャリアンカタンカラニアンナーパラングイッタッターエピャッバンニャーシー
生まれはなくなりましたと
なすべきことをなし終えたと
これからやることは全部何もないんだというふうな
状態になりましたと そこで阿羅漢になりましたということで終わりますね
アンニャタローコーパナーヤスマアンゴリマーローアラハッタンアホーシー
ここで阿羅漢になります
阿羅漢になるまでは 一般の人々とはもう関係持たなかったんです
あの特別な戒律も まあ一応
それで完了だからね やることないんだからね
やること終わったんだからね
それで他のエピソードなんです
アトゥコアヤスマアンゴリマーロブッバネサメアニワセッターパトチーバラマーダーヤサーヴァッティンピンダーヤパーヴィシー
また他のエピソードでアンゴリマーラ尊者がこの托鉢を出かける
テーナコーパナサメーナアンジェーネピレッドキットーアヤスマトアンゴリマーラッサカーエーニパタティ
アンジェーネピレッドキット
レッドっていうのはあの小さな石ですね
で どこかに誰かが小さな石でも投げちゃうと
それが行ってアンゴリマーラ尊者の体に当たると
アンジェーネピダンドゥーキットーアヤスマトアンゴリマーラッサカーエーニパタティ
野良犬でも追い出そうと思って
何かちょっとした棒とかね
木の枝とか持って もうこうやって殴っちゃうと
これが行ってアンゴリマーラ尊者の体に当たると
アンジェーネピサッカラキッターアヤスマトアンゴリマーラッサカーエーニパタティ
まあレッドは大きな石でサッカラっていうのはすごい小さい石かな
訳はどうなってますかね
サッカラっていうのは小さな石で
レッドっていうのは結構大きい石でっていうことでね
アトコアヤスマアンゴリマーロビンネーナシーセーナ
頭がもう怪我して ビンナっていうのは割れたっていうことなんですけど
まあ怪我に使う言葉で頭が怪我してローヒテーナガランテーナ
血がこうやってゴロゴロボロボロとボロボロと流れと
ビンネーナパッテーナ
鉢ももう土でできた鉢ですよね
それももう壊れちゃって
ビッッパハリターヤサンガーティヤ
衣もあっちこち破られて
エーナバガヴァーテーノペサンカメ
それでお釈迦様のところに血が出てくるわ
衣はボロボロで 鉢も割れちゃって
誰かに殴られたでしょうかね
それははっきりはしませんですけどね
アッサコーバガヴァーアヤスマタアンゴリマーランドゥーラトアーガッチャンと
アンゴリマーラ尊者は遠くから来る来ると見たんですね
そこでアンゴリマーラ尊者が礼をしたりとか
話す前にお釈迦様が喋るんですよ
だから随分お釈迦様のこういう態度
途端で見えますよ 普通は向こうは喋るまでは喋りません
で ずっと黙っているんですよ
あるいは他の誰かに説法しているとかね
説法している時は誰も喋りませんで
そうでないとお釈迦様ずっと目を閉じて黙っているんです
それで相手が喋ると 何でしょうかとか喋るんですけど
この場合は来て挨拶する前にもお釈迦様はすぐ喋るんですね
何を言います？アディワーセーシトワンブラーフマナ
ブラーフマナっていうのは偉大なる人
バラモン人を阿羅漢を呼ぶ言葉なんですね
アディワーセーシ まあ忍耐しなさいと
アディワーセーシトワンブラーフマナ
忍耐しなさいと ヤッサコトワンカッマッサヴィパケーナバホーニヴァッサーニバホーニヴァッササターニバホーニヴァッササタサハサーニレーパッチヤーシ
あなたはたくさん年 もう１０0年
たくさん１００年 たくさん１万
こといわゆるもうたくさん長い間っていうことなんですね
バフーにワッサに ワッサっていうのは年のことで
一年とか二年とか それたくさん
一で数えるともうたくさんで
では百で数えるともうものすごいたくさんだと
百単位で数えたってもワッササハッサーに千単位で数えても
一千年は一で数えたっても
ものすごい数字が大きくなるんだと
何千年ではなくて 二年と言えば二千年
三と言えば三千年という数字で数えたっても
もう十六八で終わりじゃあないんだよと
ニレイパッチギアス地獄に落ちて
もう苦しむことになったんだと
なっている このカンマ
業ですね その業だよと
あんた地獄に落ちたらもう何千何億年かっていうことは知らないほど長い時間
あんたは地獄で苦しむはずでしたと
あんたやった悪業を見ると
それぐらい悪いことをした人だよと
あんたは タッサトンラークナそれなのに今はバラモンカンマッサリパーカン
その業の得報いがディッテダメは目の前で
パティサンヘーで 自分の目の前で今自分が経験しているんだと
でもこれで悟ってるんだから
今世で終わっちゃいますよ
だからこれぐらいで終わりますよと
人に殴られて怪我して
まあこれも破られて それぐらいで終わっちゃいます
大したことないけど もし悟ったらなかったならば
もう何兆万年かとわからないことでした
だからもう何億何兆万年も苦しむべきのできるはずでした
の 何て言ったっけ 業が
悪業が もうちょっと怪我するだけ済んでますから
だからまあ忍耐我慢しなさいと
まあ一番の焦点は このこれから出てくるゲーで
もう時間はなくなりましたけど
ゲーに行きましょうか
味は後にしましょうか
じゃあやります これ説明しようと思ったら
これはもうかなりかかりますよ
で ほとんどこの北経で出てきたゲーですよ
ほとんど ですから 説明は一応
して
あるんです だからこれ一番目のゲーヨーチャプッビーパマッジットはパッチャーソーナッパマッジェティソーイマンローカンパバーセティアッバームトーチャンディマってい
うのはパティパダーにも書きましたし
プッベー前ですね パマッジットは怠って生活をしていい加減でもう野生みたいな生活で
でもファッチャーソーナッパマッジット後ですぐもうしっかり直すんですね
立ち直るんですね その人ソーイマンローカンパバーセその人はこの世を照らすんだよと
アッバームットーチャンディマ雲から出てくる月のようにこの世は照らします
言いたいのはもう立ち直れという話ですよ
人間には ずっと死ぬまでこの汚い生き方やるなよと
いくらいつっても体のことやら食い物のことやら
そういうことにしか考え方はないでしょうに
だからそんなのだったらもう過去はもう決まってるんです
だからいくらか道徳の方で生きる目的を変えないと
なんで何のために生きてる？ただ道徳を守って善行為をして
普通は野生動物はやらないことをやるやるために生きてるんだよと
だから人間の傲慢ですから
傲慢捨てないから人間は偉いと
偉くないんですよ 普通に言えば動物の方が偉いんですから
道徳もありますから 何の欲求もないのに
決まりやら何で守ってるでしょう
人間で決まりもないし
道徳もないし 全くもう感情で
もう野生で 例えばお腹が空いたら獲物でも取って食べるのは普通動物もやってますけど
量があるでしょうに 人間どうですかね
食べるものでも量が知らないでしょうに
一人人間っていうのはもう千人ぐらい食べるのもの食べるもので
一人で一人ににじんでいるでしょうね
時々一人の人間の財産があると見ると
もう国一つ養ったっても大丈夫ぐらいでしょうに
時々もう何万着でも服持ってる人々いるでしょうに
だからそれが道徳ですかね
動物だったらお腹が空いたら何か獲物を取って食べて
それでまたずっと知らんぷりをしてる
自分の体上に飛んで行ったって全然攻撃しません
お腹が空いてないんだから
それだけで自然 動物は守ってるでしょうに
特にこの肉食動物っていうのは本当に少ないんですよ
食べる量は不思議に少ない
で 虎とかライオンとか一週間に一回ぐらいしか食べないんですよ
で 獲物を取られたら それは今日も食べて
明日も食べて とにかくいっぱい食べる
それからもうもう何もしない
次の日も 次の日も 次の日も
元気になったからでもう一匹取ろうと全然ないんですよ
それで植える瞬間になってくると
もう一匹取ろうと それでもうまくいかなかったら次の日でしょ
だから立派だと思いますよ
そういう生き方に 生き方に立っても
自然にはもうね 最小限の迷惑で生きてると
それなのに人間っていうのはもう傲慢というと
ですから見ればこの自然にもう最小ではなくて最大の損害を与えている生き方で
それこそものすごい罪でしょうに
自然に最大の損を与える
人も殺すは もう大量殺人もするは
動物も殺すは 海は汚すは
川は汚すは 空気まで汚すはと
汚せるもんですかね この大気圏というのを汚しちゃったんだから
だからそれでも足らないと
もっと汚す方法ないかと
もっと儲かる方法ないかという生き方だから
もう来世はもう決まってますよ
遊びじゃないんだからね
こうやってちっぽけな地球でいてね
もう宇宙のところから見れば
人間っていうのは見えるぐらいんですかね？見えるんですかね？我々の程度から見れば
蟻一匹のもう百分の一ぐらいで
それも大きすぎですからね
そんなにいて もう地球まで破壊すると言ったら
だからこんな大胆なことを言ったってもね
できるわけないでしょうに
だから道徳ぐらい守れば
心の力っていうのは偉大なる力あるでしょうに
そんなちょっとの不自然をちょっと変えるっていうことは何のこともないんです
まあですから このこちらで言ってるのも
だから人間が悪いことをしているんだったら
それはもう今までやったことだから
そこでまあそんな後悔したり
ガチャガチャ言うんじゃなく
それでストップして それから頑張ってください
パッチャーソーナッパマッチャティ
それから怠ることはないんだと
十年前で何とかしましたとか
そんなのはもう偉そうに言うんですよ
瞑想会に来たっても 私はすごくそれ嫌なんです
その話さえも 千人振るんですよ
そういったって 私はちょっとすごく怒って
自分の言葉でいろいろそんなのはどうでもいいことで
これから頑張ればいいでしょうに
それで瞑想はしない 瞑想会に来て
それで一応ちょっと相談したいんですけどとかね
だからせっかく来たってもやらない
そういうこのもうけしからんな性格というかね
根性ない性格ではもうこれでも人間かと言いたいでしょうかと
ですから私は人格のことを言ってます
私 身のたたかにしていてもね
あれはすごい心が強い人格なんです
それはもう何万人来たっても
もうそう簡単には変えられません
それほどそんな大したことないんですよ
誰にでもできることで
ですから まあ良いことを
それしなさいよと もう今までの人生はこんなのはどうでもいい
そこでストップとピリオドと
どんな悪いことしたってもいいや
そんなことはと さささっと修行して立派な人間になってくださいと
生まれ変わりなさいと
生まれ変わったぞと それで振り返ったってもニコニコと
そうなんですね 十年前に私はこんなことやっちゃったんだよとかね
冗談で言えるぐらいのもう人格はなりますよ
だからそういう人格 生まれ変わった人だったら
今までやってきた数々の悪行も本当に教科書になるんですよ
生まれ変わった人は何のことなく明るく言うんだから
他の人々にあんた方は知ってますかね？私はこういうこんな今立派な人間なんですけど
実は昔はこういうこともやったんだよと
こういうこともやったんだよと
時々この刑務所から来た人やら
そういう反省した人とか
時々たまにテレビに出たり喋ったりするあるでしょうに
その場合は その人々は完全に更生していますよ
だからその場合は普通の人より私はすごくありがたさを感じるんです
立派な人やと ちゃんと更生して
今淡々と自分がやった悪いことを言うんだよと
だから更生しないと過去の悪いことは隠すんですよ
隠す人はもうとんでもないんですよ
でも心が治ってないと隠すしか道もないんですね
心治った人は隠すことさえもしない
堂々と言う 言って人も
じゃあ私もやるぞということになりません
やっぱり良くないんだよとわかるでしょうに
だから人生を更生する
更生すること自体も 他の人々にものすごいいい例なんですよ
例えば私がそうしたことがないんだぞと言ったっても
大したことないんですよ
そういう環境で そういう教育で育てられたんだから
私にでもそうやって悪いことをした人が更生すれば
私はその人を前に出して
その人にあなた行ってくださいと言うんです
私たちの場合は別に自然のことで殺すてないんです
今はゴキブリと腹が立ってますけどね
もうもうなかなか まあもうまあ一応もう一緒に仲間で友達みたいな感じでいるんだけど
今ちょっと出しゃばっちゃって
こうやって胸を張って自分の前に歩いたり
まあコンピューターでやってる時は足のところに来て待っていたりとかね
ちょっとやりすぎやと思ってはいるんですけど
それでもやっぱり殺虫剤なんかはもう買えないんですよ
やっぱりあれほど堂々という態度でいると
結局は信頼されてるんですよ
この人は危険じゃないと
だから取ろうとすれば取れますよ
あの本能で逃げるだけで
別に逃げる気持ちはないんです
レスリングということは
すぐ隠れたってその前そこで隠れているんだから
それでも捕まる気持ちがなくなって
この阿呆はなんだって気持ちになっちゃってね
ですから もう我々にとっては大したことない
そんなのはもう普通の生き方であって
ただ仲良く 嫌な奴なんですけど
そうやって可愛いと思ったらね
気持ちいいもんですからね
逆に でも一つ今企んでるんで
餌をやらないと 全部きっちりと
じゃあパンとかの昨日もらったものとかね
もう置くとこがなくて
で レンジの中に入れてきて
じゃあ食べてみろと できれば
餓死する 餓死にはなりませんけど
まあそういうふうなことで
やっぱりこの人間っていうのは人間ではなくてね
悪いことをしてない人っていうのはあるわけじゃないんです
それはもう決してあり得ないことで
心が悪いことをするように構成できているものなんですね
ですから 人間っていうのは悪いことをする
他の生命 生命でありながらあるならば
悪いことをするっていうことは当たり前に決まっている
そこで更生しなさいと
あるところできちんと終わったと
やめたと その人格がないと仏教徒とはなれません
やめたならばやめたと
そこですよ こちらでまあこのたくさんこの法華経から偈選んでますけど
大体そのポイントをね
アンブリマーラが人殺したんだけど
すごい人格者なんですよ
やめたならばやめた それで終わり
もう二度とやらないと
ではまあ それぐらい時間になりましたので
そろそろ終わりにします
[拍手]